[Music]
hey guys some really exciting news if
you can't get enough of us here you can
take us with you wherever you go cuz now
we are offering a podcast oh [ __ ] yes
you can take us with you wherever you go
in form of a podcast so go to the
description box below click on the links
and voila just like magic we're inside
of you guys so also don't forget to rate
us and give us five stars thank you so
much taking away Tiffany were you gonna
say if it wasn't podcast oh I don't know
what I was gonna say but it sounded
wrong that was the longest intro to the
podcast ever did my god but it was
organic and that's all people care about
anyways organisms I don't know about
that good gossip news god ruin the mood
what I know you agreed that's right
submitted by fan from Jersey victim we
Joisey PHA n Oh but Balu with money
Vietnamese sauce researchers are
suggesting that gossip may actually be
good for you Korean people must live
forever then oh yeah you know they did
it [ __ ] it would you call it a
eavesdropping study and 35% of
conversations are gossip yeah that's how
much we talk about other people god damn
that's how we socialize though yeah
pretty much yeah I say gossip is okay as
long as the other person knows that
you're gonna tell the story
I thought gossip meant it was fake stuff
does that not look awesome
no that's rumors okay then I like boss
we're talking about she's me I love
because gossip doesn't always have to be
negative right it could it could be
about like oh you know about so-and-so
got a new car oh really which car was
bad yeah it's like isn't that gossip
still yes I mean no matter what like
it's about another person that isn't
there exactly yeah okay yeah but boo
does a study saying cuz I like it it
makes me feel good well no cause a lot
of people
like say gossip is horrible we should
never gossip about people I just don't
got people who say are the ones that
gossip I think if you make up [ __ ] about
people of rumors and then if you're
telling gossip with negative intent
that's [ __ ] up yes I was they are
mentioning here that apparently about
three to four percent of gossip is
actually malicious so that's good very
small dude that's how you get stuff with
that with that little girl Millie
Jackson Browne that's a rumor that's
part of that but yeah that's right and
it blew up look at all these rumors
surrounding me everyday
that's just dope that song was really
good back in a day man it's okay I'll
play it for you
alright so researchers at the University
of Texas and the University of Oklahoma
that's not ready Mercer University of
Texas it is I'm sanctioned or so they
found that if two people share a
negative feeling about a third person
then they are likely to feel closer than
if they both felt positively about that
what also didn't for them their study
it's specifically bad gossip in
comparison so hate unites like having
that common staple common enemy it
unites people I hate that [ __ ] more than
if they felt that's why you ain't got
friends Jill you gotta hate more people
together yeah man then you're gonna have
so many close friends why do you think
we're so close cuz we hate the same
[ __ ] people yeah I don't hate
anybody anymore man oh yeah you do the
biggest hater here yeah you hate people
every day you're the one that gets me to
hate people just go to his Twitter and
you'll see it that's true I am actually
a really big hater and I do realize that
I have Coolatta close friendships based
on the people that I hate exactly yeah
because we usually hate the same people
yup
you know how much time we spend talking
about people we hate man you got me
convinced
[Laughter]
there's only you know I will say this
though I don't hate a lot of people but
there are a few people that have stuck
around me enough right I've known them
long enough to write hate them like it's
so odd now I'm like dude I shouldn't
hate you this much but I [ __ ] do like
I legit like if I see you like I
literally want to take the [ __ ]
bottom of your [ __ ] mouth and rip
that [ __ ] off and then [ __ ] dangle it
around my neck
there's literally only two or three
people in the world that I feel that way
about yeah yeah but they're close to you
they're your friends they're close
enough to the point where I have to see
their [ __ ] face but because I've
grown up as an adult now and I'm a lot
more mature no you're not you're wearing
the [ __ ] worst socks to prove that
point this is even more mature as it
gets so let me I say my point this is
really growing it's a little too
grown-up actually yeah that's grandpas
exactly but I've grown up now so to the
point where I could see that be very
simple yeah I mean like I don't have to
say anything bad but I can very much
ignore them when they talk to me you
know hey let's get a question yeah when
you put those socks on you can't put it
on in one slide you gotta put each just
put on one slow oh you can put this all
one slide you can show the first the
first time that I did it it was very
hard but then when you take it off
inside out oh so when you pick it up so
when you take it off it's done you just
do this do this how do you roll it back
down don't you do you like a balloon
she's now done this is now like a latex
glove so what's just like this boy it's
a one done I check that the shoes he's
wearing with these socks oh we're in
these [ __ ] 4,000 they're cult or does
like the sand we want to hear something
funny
these aren't even mine well whose are
they wait there was a joke in Hawaii
somebody somebody stole my sandals and
they left there so I took theirs what ha
ha ha you know they've got athlete's
feet I don't know it was a salt one
you know word on the street is that
people who wear toe socks tend to have
athlete's foot and it's by wearing toe
socks that helps what streets are you on
- yeah
how many streets what's athlete's foot
when your foots itchy yeah in your face
I already had athlete's foot already
once well that's what she's saying that
people who are down the street is right
but I only started wearing these
recently because the more time okay you
gotta man it up a little bit there with
the Muay Thai kickboxing yep
so in your [ __ ] face I do it to kick
people's apps they do it they do it to
people I'm not a fall loser I might wear
it looks kind of the ball yes you wear
it there's two people they were all like
Rambo and they were so uncomfortable
because I mean there's a couple things
so like I know like a couple of you who
are the Vibrams or they wear like you
know like wrestling shoes but they're
[ __ ] expensive the wrestling shoes
you can buy some 50 long ones yeah but
the vibrant for 40 bucks they're like 40
or 30 dollars you can look way cooler no
I don't want so much of those socks
eighty dollars no these were five but
five dollars for like a pack of 10 oh my
god that's five dollars better that's
she Amazon dude no one else wants to buy
that [ __ ] dude I just told you latex
gloves these are done now oh no anyway
back to the gossip thing so dutch
researchers said that hearing gossip
about others made the subjects more
reflective on themselves
oh let you learn about yourself while
talking [ __ ] about others I agree with
that the other way around like if you
hear doctor about you it makes you think
about yourself and like hear gossip
about me yeah oh my god people are like
oh man look at that guy he's always like
like ego just going over another old
[ __ ] and they stop talking about myself
but gossip never gets back to me though
huh my god [ __ ] I'm about a close friend
of mine though I cut this you know good
like hey you know what tip is kind of a
[ __ ] other al you'll talk about it that
way oh okay chill homie that's right
that's not gossip that's [ __ ] talking
isn't that different now didn't talk
about tip that way again I'll make you
wear toe socks [ __ ] like it's like you
know something that's true
that happened but you're laughing at
your friends that's gossip right or like
that's got gossip is like your friend
got an accident but then like it was
kind of funny because their car broke in
a funny way but it was sad you know
funny way you broke your arm like what
broke is [ __ ] interesting thing is a
lot of the things that you make funny
before you get on it as well besides the
Apple watch what us that is a lot of
things the Apple watch you were kind of
going ham on it for a second you're like
hey I got two cute
oh dude you [ __ ] giant shut up so geo
gets closer to people by clowning on the
things they have that's the gossip but
it's not gossip on people it's gossip on
because she wants it too I'm usually
doing it to their face so they don't
think it's gossip that's true just copy
a [ __ ] beat you up a [ __ ] of a [ __ ] a
[ __ ]
in this article they're saying you've
become really close when you hate the
same person yeah so that's the kind of
gossip let's talk some [ __ ] today well
specifically for that like what they're
talking about here yes that's I do have
those moments where I have to be kind of
like Hollywood about certain people and
I find out that they don't like them
either I'm like thank God [ __ ] yeah we
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
hell yeah you good I mean I just trust
them more you know like I don't think oh
you're probably talking [ __ ] behind my
back I go I trust you more because you
don't like that [ __ ] for the same
reason I've I've learned now to like
think about the group as a census
because there was a time where I had a
little bit to drink and there was a guy
that I didn't like this you got no
here's to but he was at the table and he
kept under I talked to me and I he he
knows I don't like him but he kept on
trying to be fair and buddy-buddy with
me and they just just over and over and
I just kept staring at him without
saying anything he goes you don't like
me do you outside you [ __ ] think move
from the table and go over there
cuz that's me Dana I've never seen you
so mean did I really
hate this guy though like I legit hate
this dude because he is a terrible
person he's a [ __ ] mooch he he's one
of those people that only sticks around
somebody only if he could get something
out of him oh that's horrid got anything
his whole life and so whatever he tries
to work on is based off of somebody
else's work and I hate people like that
so he doesn't do anything on his own
merit and so he wants to have all the
glory without the work so every time
we're hanging he always comes to and he
was like oh yo I got this project I'm
like get the [ __ ] away from me yeah in
junior high we had a name for people
like that we call them bouncers cuz
they're bouncing on dicks all day
[ __ ] bounce I literally hate people
like that it's like yo man if you if you
want to bring something to the table
then by all means do it but you can't
wait for us to do something and say hey
I was a part of the - right you know
it's like what the [ __ ] man like he like
came on set to pick up trash and then
now he was the director like that yeah
one of those type of people
[Music]